i feel like you do get a lot of credit
as far as
some of the things you just said but i
don't think you get enough credit when
it comes to some of the artists
who you kind of have taken over your
under your shoulder like over your
shoulder
before they were quote unquote popping
you know what i'm saying i feel like i
always see you embracing
younger artists before the rest of the
world really knows who they are
um i know recently you talked about uh
famous dex
was sitting sleeping on your couch you
know what i'm saying he was supposed to
sign you originally
yes and then that obviously didn't have
didn't happen uh what happened there he
just he's yeah
he's just he chose another label even
though you gave him a place to stay
yes damn i feel like um
you there's a bunch of artists like that
though you know what i'm saying that you
really kind of you know you were kind of
the first
guy to really [ __ ] with them that of
some notoriety like
who are some of the artists that you
feel like you kind of helped help
school a little bit when they first were
coming up you know what i'm saying not
say that you like put them on or nothing
but just some artists that you feel like
you really kind of helped
talking about that like i feel like the
proof is in the pudding you know what
i'm saying do the history do the
youtubes do the
i'm done giving away clout i'm done
giving away free promo i'm done saying
rapper name
if i helped you cool if you made it cool
if you didn't make it cool
i don't i don't have no i'm done like i
don't even kill no more you know what
i'm saying
would you ever take a label job like if
a label wanted to hire soldier boy to be
there yes
the vice president i supposed to be the
ceo of
one of the major labels right now i
supposed to be the president of one of
these labels right now
look how many artists i discovered for
you that's what i was gonna say artists
that y'all bumping for the last half
many years
been me so why shouldn't i have a
position at the labor i just found all
the talent that y'all
that y'all listening to you could be a r
for sure you'll run the whole a
r the post you heard them ceo
oh you got a ear ain't no a no ain't no
little nun i need to hold
i need everything they tripping that's
why i got my own label though but see i
wasn't the artist that was putting these
artists in contracts
i know what it's like to be in the
contract you were just helping them out
genuinely
no it wasn't that [ __ ] y'all supposed to
keep it real and still did the paperwork
but off the jump i'm not gonna just put
you in no crazy country and then your
career something happened to your career
and you looking at me and then you're
right right
right so i'm thinking off the strength
we working off a handshake you we
working out loyalty and your word is all
you got in this world
so we working off your word i'm thinking
we finna ride it out till we
we're gonna ride it all the way out
right that's what happened with with
with dex i'm assuming that's what
happened with everybody
i hate tripping right right now i'm
saying you're just on a new wave right
now you work
on yourself no more free
man much love much respect whatever but
you know i got my new label 2021 i just
saw my new artist flow malcolm
malcolm yes atlanta he got the atlanta
going crazy i gotta bring him out to the
west coast so y'all can tap in with him